okay so again not
not too harsh so
you always have the front inward kazushi
on the back outward position
okay so
uh we're gonna work on that
i'm gonna put him in it ballistically
okay so
uh he first has this and we'll just work
watch your sympathetic flexion and
you're looking for mass displacement so
don't kiss the target
and don't kiss the target i will
displace where his leg is by replacing
it
with my leg okay
okay let's go okay so uh
just like yesterday's drill uh there's a
sweet spot so the guy
was coming into the range right and ooh
is where i threw the kick so
same thing here uh down
and he has his car okay and he's moving
into ranger
is when i'm gonna do the kick okay so
we're gonna do it with the bag first
it's gonna be awkward don't worry
okay and you kind of reduce the power so
you could you got to walk
in with that shield now you're going to
save this place
[Applause]
so the same thing he goes walks in i'm
too far away
i had the wrong time he walks in i'm
gonna be too late
so just working on the timing
okay let's go okay so if i take uh
keyhole and so when i go like this you
see how his
foot his stance changes so he's uh
got this foot worse out than the back
foot
so same thing as he walks in oh i kicked
that foot that way and here it is right
don't go back
check in
check
all right uh you're not just doing a
kick and then you're doing it
there's there's there's something that
you get allows you to have
and it's not just the throat so he's
coming in
boom i do the displacement and what i'm
going to do
is trap him in between my hip
and my arm though i'm here like that
i'm i'm looking for that i'm looking for
control
of his purses
there's there's many ways to control you
can have
fair hives uh you can have locks
all right this is just like a body lock
right right in here
this part here and it is much
easier to get and less committal
less committed than the other one so
when it goes south i can still do
something
so boom i'm looking for my hip
to create this pressure with the upper
arm
don't leave the hips out and you're just
on the arm
then you're just gonna hit someone like
wwe style
okay so boom it hits
there's a little slight funny lock in
here
where you're checking out his options
this is what um key honeydew nugget does
but usually it's left out we leave it
out
we go like this
but it's in there it's in there
it's in here
now i'm just making sure i have it
because i don't have this grip
to control him
okay